Rebecca Rebecca j'ai un personnage très
intelligent, elle n'est pas tout ce qu'elle semble
beaucoup de slide it vilain je pense sur
la page qu'elle a lu aspirer tout le personnage
mais j'ai vu que comme une sorte de vie amusante une partie
de mon travail consiste à se rapprocher des gens qui
ont à proximité  le personnage de mon employeur
Justin finit par se faire escroquer pour
travailler pour cette entreprise le gars qui la
dirige Ivan bluff Rebecca est qu'il est une sorte
de bras droit non seulement elle est
belle mais vous ne savez jamais vraiment
ce qui se passe avec elle elle finit par
jouer au bowling  personnage cela
interfère en quelque sorte avec le plan elle et bloquer
ont été intéressants pour moi de jouer un
personnage dans ce monde elle permet que
cela se produise autour d'elle mais cela n'est pas
nécessairement d'accord avec vous savez je suis
avec vous
vous